warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised
hello and welcome to LED live the show
where we use the light of Christ to
expose the darkness found in media and
our culture today and today we're doing
a highly requested video on a very
controversial movie but this is the show
you know this is what we do so we're
gonna have some fun we want to welcome
Michael Bonanno to the show from Florida
thank you so much for joining us in this
discussion thank you for having me
yeah so today we're gonna talk a lot is
joker harmless or is it the most
triggering movie of 2019 find out on
this episode of LED live so if you've
been watching us from week to week and
are wondering how you can support us one
of the ways is on patreon and the link
is in the description below we have a
bunch of perks on there from behind the
scenes to t-shirts exclusive t-shirts
and stickers and whatnot and I'm
speaking of supporters we want to give a
big shout out to Amelia from New Mexico
she sent us these awesome tumblers thank
you so much one for each of us arm on
this cold day yeah even got our names on
them so so you want to give a big shout
out to her and we thank you all for your
love and for your supports if you're
looking at Scottie and Mike and you're
like man those are some awesome t-shirts
they're wearing yeah I'm representative
a for you for all those haters on this
video that's true you can find those
links in the bar below it really helps
us out as a ministry and it helps to
share the gospel to where your witness
in a cool and fashionable way so today
we're just gonna jump right into it
we're talking about Joker have you guys
ever seen the movie no no no have you
seen a Michael you haven't have a lot to
say
oh how many times have you seen it
Michael I've seen it twice nice nice so
good you you you can remember VIN detail
I'm sure the scenes unfortunately
so leading up to the film there was a
lot of press on it and for me just
looking at it I'm I saw the headlines
and I'm like okay that's for me to run
in the opposite direction but the
opposite effect happened all these
headlines were showing in the news and
it seems like it helped to the movie
because it's like one of the biggest
movies of 2019 despite its controversy I
mean their marketing machine was out
like crazy because our feed was just I
mean it was like every other video is
about the Joker yeah I mean you just you
just saw it everywhere so I mean for for
for a little film like this to be
promoted so heavily it's pretty amazing
to me made a grip load of money didn't
it I think on a low budget when it the
number one rated R movie I think this is
like budget to income ratio thing yeah I
think it was greater than Deadpool Wow
because Deadpool is like yes well even
ratio because Deadpool was a eighty
million dollar film Wow the first one
interesting but I think Joker was the
less than that wasn't it I think it was
like 60 or something like that in it and
it outperform that so like they really
made a lot yeah let's take a look at
these headlines Joker draws a direct
connection between mental health and
violence says insider and then families
in Aurora shooting victims expressed
concerns about Joker in a letter
directly to Warner Brothers they sent a
letter to Warner Brothers undercover
police officers in theaters as Warner
Brothers Joker opens Wow Joker didn't
incite violence but it sure inspired
paranoia and stupidity
Joker audience please cinema after man
shouts Allahu Akbar Allah Akbar
in possible robbery attempt going back
to the stupidity and paranoia Joker
Joker is the fourth highest-grossing DC
movie ever internationally I would be
the number one do you know so the number
one DC film of all time I just looked it
up it's actually Aquaman aqua not
expected that into it I guess the story
yeah I just looked it up you can do it
yeah Office Mojo this is like
highest-grossing movie ever
DC's highest-grossing movie ever Joker
viewers around the world
walk out of cinemas and urge film band
and actually want to read a review for
you guys someone said it's too
terrifying Joker viewers around the
world walk out of movie theaters and
urge cinemas to band the ultraviolent
film saying it glamorizes gun crime and
deals with mental health issues in a
triggering way so I was seeing these
reviews about the fans were walking out
and I thought that was you know
different cuz usually I mean a fans
gonna stick around no matter what and so
I was like man this is really messed up
so I started looking at my feed and I
saw other people sharing this you know
article about it being triggering and
I'd started looking at the comments and
there were people in there saying like
is it they were conversating like is
this safe to take my kids to and and
some people were like I wouldn't ever go
see it myself and some were like well my
daughter is 13 and I think she's mature
enough and I mean it's pretty crazy I
mean these are adults walking out and I
was seeing people talking about taking
their kids to see this it's it's rated R
right so the APA in my opinion you could
be 45 years old and still not be mature
enough to see this movie interesting
yeah good point the the MPAA does not
recommend that you take a child to a
rated R film yeah for good reasons
reading on it yeah yeah I did see them
say some of the comments were like yeah
there was way too many kids
that theater yeah I mean they're in
there wow that's crazy
so fans aren't weren't the only ones
walking out of things that actors
themselves walked out of interviews over
certain questions I would them
Joaquin Phoenix may play a man with an
uncontrollable cackle and director Todd
Phillips as Joker but he certainly
wasn't laughing in an interview about
the dark and gritty comic-book movie
Phoenix ooh stars has failed comedian
Arthur Fleck in the Joker origin story
film released in on October 4th sat down
for an interview with The Telegraph's
Robbie Colin during the conversation
Colin asked Phoenix if he was worried
that his performance might inspire
real-world copycat killers the question
apparently took Phoenix by surprise
Phoenix reportedly replied why why would
you no no according to Colin Phoenix
then stood up shook his hand and left
the interview roughly an hour later
largely spent talking with Warner
Brothers PR team Phoenix returned to
finish the interview the actor explained
that he left because he had never
considered the possibility and needed
time to try and figure out an
appropriate response but the interview
concluded without being exam suring the
question and the director Todd Phillips
he also tried to avoid answering it
instead of just coming out and talking
about it he pointed the finger at other
films that are probably more violent
that are not stirring so much
controversy I think that you know Aurora
is obviously a horrible horrible
situation and I know and and and but
even that is not something you blame on
the movie and quite frankly if you do
your own research about Aurora that
gentleman wasn't even going in as Joker
that was misreported his hair was dyed
red he was having a obviously a mental
breakdown and there's something
horrifying about it but it wasn't
related to it outside of the fact that
it happened at a movie theater um but
this is not the thing that the movie is
trying to represent this is not the you
know the movie still takes place in a
fictional world it can have real world
implications opinions but it's a
fictional character in a fictional world
that's been around for 80 years the one
that bugs me more is in toxic white male
thing when you go oh I just saw John
wick 3 he's a white male
300 people and everybody's laughing and
hooting and hollering why does this
movie get held to different standards it
doesn't it honestly doesn't make sense
to me
and I'm not saying John wick should be
saying these are what this is you know
this is the movie world it's a good
point
I mean you know how is it that we're so
exposed to such crazy violence but then
everybody wants to call you know like
the trailer we're watching in a day
where you actually saw in slow-motion
the guys head blow off like some videos
of Vin Diesel movie yeah and it's like
in slow motion is exploding like a
watermelon like that's okay you know
like oh my goodness
yeah but just because that's the case
does that mean that we should just avoid
the questions yeah and if you want to
talk about mental health have you ever
seen American Psycho I mean that dude
right right I think he wanted words for
that oh you question that Hakeem is
going to walking sorry is going to get
awards for this right yeah oscars and
whatnot says says good the media said
the media I wonder if they're hopeful in
in sort of a weird way hopeful that
something bad would happen because
that's just great PR yeah you know what
I mean like all of a sudden somebody
walks out and now everybody's talking
about that you know I mean it was like
on Halloween that family that walked out
of the Addams Family yeah I mean I
wonder how much like I mean I hope that
did some good with people going I don't
want to expose my kids to this but I
wonder if it also works on the reverse
side as well people want to go see it
because they're like dude if people are
walking out of this movie that's what
it's so bad like how's it making so much
money I mean it only makes money because
people go and see it yeah yeah so many
people are walking out and saying this
is terrible
well as people go I saw people sharing
that article about it being triggering
of people walking out and most of the
ones that shared it said I'd had no
desire T and watch this movie except now
I do yeah people want to see if it is
that bad it was the suite of articles
it's like they're saying it's bad
because of gun violence is bad because
it's true going to mental health but
it's not really saying why so it's
probably out of curiosity that I mean
there's a there's a lot of movies with
gun violence though and I think like
that clip we played during the video
game talk with with
ben shapiro you know it's like we're
exposed to an incredible amount of
violence that doesn't necessarily mean
that somebody's gonna go out and cause
that violent act that I really I believe
that but I think that there's a majority
minority of people that potentially
could and this could just kick him over
the edge
yeah so if they're sympathizing or
they're
what do you call identified identifying
with the main character and saying wow
I'm like that too that could be enough
to push someone over the edge that's
what I was well then the question is
because of that small group should we
banned the movie for the large
population that's where it gets tricky
yeah well getting into free speech yeah
okay Mike I wanna hear a little bit of
your background before we get into this
share with the audience for those that
may be watching you know talk a little
bit about maybe your experience with
comic books if you can well so growing
up the first thing I ever saw
comic book wise with spider-man actually
Spiderman was the one thing that helped
me get to the point where I could find
Christ but throughout this whole time I
really fell in love with the idea of
people trying to save people with these
godlike powers anyways through that I
found out about Batman who honestly is
my least favorite her hero anybody who
likes Batman's gonna hate me for that
and then finding out about the Joker my
whole life before Christ was pretty much
dictated by comics and even then I knew
that the Joker was not a good character
like very well written and not obviously
a fan favorite but not a good character
this guy has three different people all
dressing up as the Joker claiming to be
the Joker and all having different
identities and all this type of stuff
and this character is just nuts in
general he's overtaken our Messiah
and created a form of an anti Justice
League with the help of Lex Luthor it's
just not a fun time and so and he
doesn't have a due date its origin does
he like no one knows where he came from
so that's what I was gonna get into with
the movie when it comes to the movie
this is a potential origin story the
Joker doesn't have a real name he
doesn't have a real origin and the
comic-book Batman and Killing Joke the
Joker says if I'm going to have an
origin I prefer it to be multiple choice
he doesn't even remember it himself and
so sometimes his name is Jack Napier as
we see in the 1989 film sometimes his
name is Joe Curt Jo e ke RR sometimes
it's even Joe Chill who is the man who
killed Batman's parents and so this
movie gives him a new name Arthur Fleck
and gives a whole new dynamic it's kind
of similar to The Killing Joke origin
but in this one he's semi taking care of
his mother we're in The Killing Joke he
was trying to make sure his wife and
future child were safe this movie is one
of the dark I've ever seen
Wow really I would not suggest it to
anybody you want to give it a summary of
the film
I wouldn't more than the highly P PG
version of their summary of the film
this movie goes like this Arthur Fleck
who is the character we will from here
on out referred to as the Joker is a
comedian he wants to be a comedian but
he's working as
clown and he is constantly being beaten
on not too dissimilar to you know what
I've been through or what other people
who've been being on have gone through
he's in a bad part of the neighborhood
and therefore it makes sense for this
type of crime to occur to him and so one
of his what is a co-worker's gives him a
gun they are not allowed to have guns in
his job because they're constantly going
to Children's Hospital and performing
his clowns so he has this gun and while
he's performing it drops and therefore
because it drops he gets fired he's down
on his luck now he's still living with
his mom and then he sees these people
beating on this girl not really so much
as beating but verbally assaulting her
and he starts laughing not because he
thinks it's funny but because he has a
mental condition where he's forced to
laugh or so we're led to believe that
later we find out that it was a thing
that his mother told him because he
would constantly laugh in inappropriate
situations so they turned him their
attention to him beat him up and he
shoots them because you know they found
a gun and then this leads to a whole
spiral of events in the end he kills the
host of a show that he idolized and
throughout this you're not even sure
what is real or fake you don't know in
terms of his I mean the events he's
making it up in his mind yes he has
schizophrenia
well pseudo schizophrenia as I said in
the podcast he sued us to get afrien
eeeh he has depression manic depression
and obviously he's some sort of psycho
if his mom had to lie and tell him that
he has a mental condition to where he
just laughs at random points even has
the card to show it like why do you
think this is funny he pulls out a card
says please excuse me
I have a mental condition mm-hmm and
what are people's response to that in
the Mallika doctors know either yeah
what are people's response to the card
in the movie some people are like okay
other people are like this is this is
falsified this is garbage and then they
just start beating him up at some points
he can't even get the card out and then
they're just like oh you think this is
funny
kick his butt I guess that's that's
that's pretty accurate to society today
how there's like this taboo or stigma
around mental health even when there's
proof like hey I struggle with something
the response may not be what we would
like yeah but this sounds like a case of
the oppressed becoming the oppressor
I think it's definitely that way but
what made it so dark
I mean why why is it so disturbing it's
disturbing with the way that everything
is shot it's um it's this really dark
film both tonally and like the way it's
directed it's always gray there's never
light shining except for the parts with
his girlfriend who you realize doesn't
even know he exists and he's been
imagining it the whole time and that's
at the end when you find that out is
when you kind of realize like what in
this is true there's certain things that
pointed out to be truth certain things
could be true but it's like this weird
limbo state you're constantly and trying
to figure out what is real and what is
fake but because all the parts that are
most likely real are the violent parts
like the violent parts seem to be the
only real thing cuz here's a little
moment of happiness and then somebody
dies here's a little bit of moment of
happiness and then somebody beats him up
here's a little bit of moment of
happiness oh wait that was in your head
because this guy is now calling you a
bad word
so they're really taking the audience on
a on a sort of a roller coaster of you
know up and down and high and low and
they're kind of you know really messing
with the emotions of the audience yes
very much it's very much that and due to
that fact I had to watch it twice
because both times I walked out at
different points so what at what point
did you walk out and what made you like
I shouldn't be here or I mean what like
like give me a little background of that
because why why would you walk out of a
movie you know if if people watching you
know we kind of battle this all the time
oh it doesn't matter I'm not affected by
what I watch and and yet here you are
someone who is clearly a fan of comic
books and comic movies but yet this one
I find it very fascinating that you were
unwilling to sit through it so kind of
get to the nut of that the part where I
walked out at the first one was actually
his appearance at the Wayne mansion the
Wayne Manor because of the steps it took
to get there the tone of it was so dark
he starts talking to Bruce who's a
little kid at this point it takes place
in the 80s so the Bruce is a baby
essentially right before you know it's
before his father and mother died so
he's just a child
and Joker is talking to him like I'm
your brother like talking this very
high-pitched like hearing voice and it's
just not in it's not enjoyable with the
eyes that he has the the creepy smile
literally sticking his thumbs into the
child's mouth and make him smile like
why so serious it just it wasn't you
know sitting well it was just this dark
thing and the way that everything was
shot kind of made it look like a horror
film interesting people people say that
this movie just
awareness to abuse and mental health and
such what is your take on that it
definitely brings awareness it
definitely does but the thing about the
fact it's bringing awareness is the way
it's bringing awareness okay like it's
guess like this guy he's clearly you
know be down on his luck he's lost his
job lost pretty much everything and he
just he's waiting for the end of the day
to get that final cigarette and like
that he wants but these people just
don't care and they be you know beat him
up because of it and for that like yes
it brings a sympathy to him it brings
all the stuff to him but when you
sympathize with this character with the
mental health you put yourself in their
shoes that's a whole point of sympathy
and the way he manages it it's not a
positive way of managing your you know
your schizophrenia or anything he has to
take drugs and he refuses to take drugs
it's not a positive awareness of it it's
a this is this guy who has it and other
people in the world have it and it's
more so not like you know what people
have this let's help them out right it's
people have this and if you have it
while you're watching it you're gonna
want to go kill some people
right because you sympathize with this
character now you know one of the
reasons that a lot of comic book fans
like Batman is because Batman is like
this most tangible human character that
people can identify with you know it's
not like everything in Batman's life is
completely polished it's not like he's
got it all together and so a lot of
people like Batman for that reason and
what's what's interesting is I'm hearing
you talk about this it's like you know
the Joker goes and the way he handles
everything it's like people's response
to that isn't
particularly great but Batman has a
terrible experience in his own life
where his parents are killed and now he
has to deal with that the rest of his
life and the way one of the ways that he
deals with it is he dresses up as Batman
and it goes around as a vigilante
exacting revenge on people who commit
you know heinous crimes or intervening
in other people's lives
and I'm wondering like is that really
healthy hmm you know what I mean what I
am well aware of what you mean and to be
honest this is why I enjoyed the comics
as a parable rather than could actually
live but I know it's not healthy
they're called Batman and psychology and
in it it actually shows the the twisted
psychology of a man who who decides to
become a bat to accept to exact
vengeance it's it's not this glamorous
or beautiful thing in fact his twist his
own twisted psychosis watching his you
know mother and father die in front of
him actually creates his own villains in
the comics he was the one who pushed or
sometimes trips or whatever
Arthur flack or Joker or Jack Napier
into the bat that caused him to go crazy
he's the reason for Hugo Strange to be
evil he's a reason for scarecrow and and
all these other characters it's not a
healthy thing to do
sure it's bit healthier then well
killing some people with a gun and and
just having fun with it but it's not
healthy because we are not supposed to
have vengeance like that we're not
supposed to have exact revenge we're
supposed to give it to God we're
supposed to let it go and forgive
which is something that this man cannot
do my God says vengeance is mine yeah it
seems like times have changed from there
just like a Miss connect between comics
and movies I don't know if you guys knew
but when Joker comics first started
coming out it had at the end of the
comic he had to be put in prison or he
had there had to be some kind of
resolution to kind of ending he couldn't
just run free and correct me from wrong
in the Joker movie he he gets away like
he it's there's no resolution at the end
of the film you go through all of he
goes to all this trauma he goes and
kills all of these people and at the end
he just walks away I believe it's like a
blood trail and to like this abyss of
nothing that says it to be continued so
how it ends is he shoots Mari Oh
Joe and you know then he gets tackled by
the cops and shot but he's able to
escape and while he escapes there's a
whole crowd of people around him and
some of them you think you know maybe
they're gonna stop him you know make
sure he gets to the please well and and
but all of them either keep their clown
masks on or put new clown masks on all
of them and then they carry him away in
this sort of this is our savior position
and they go on a rampage killing
everything and then the end of the movie
literally ends with a guy in a clown
mask walking up to little Bruce and
shoots his parents that's how the movie
ends Wow all those characters are
choosing to identify with him at the end
and kind of like throwing their their
hat in so to speak with him which kind
of reminds me of like Guy Fawkes you
know he is it's like that same kind of
like you've got all these characters
that are kind of throwing themselves in
there buying into the ideal or whatever
is it kind of like embracing the mental
health yeah they're embracing the
darkness
excuse for it in the movie is the people
they are fighting against is the
oppressor it's the you know billionaires
the one percenters that don't appear to
care for these people hmm
and you're not seeing anything from
their side you're only seeing it from
the Joker's point of view so when Thomas
Wayne tells him listen I'm not your
father what the Joker Arthur Fleck hears
is I'm not your father get out of here
mm-hmm it's he's seeing in such a
twisted view it's just not a possibility
or a a good way of seeing anything and
that is how the movie decides to portray
the people who are trying to fix the
city if you know anything about Batman
from Batman's perspective these people
are doing their best to fix a city that
is overrun by crime but from the Joker's
perspective you just seen these people
not giving any cares whatsoever I'm
making money off of it profiting off of
it yes profiting off the pain and the
suffering the two people that were shot
by the Joker in the beginning the first
two people he killed were people who
work for Wayne and and and and Thomas is
like these people were good men these
people did nothing wrong or anything
they were the top of their teams you
didn't see what they did to him what
they did d'Arthur mm-hmm
and so the Joker doesn't care mm-hmm so
thinking about society's response to
this movie and the big argument you know
this movie or any movie doesn't affect
me I'm just watching it for fun does the
brain really know the difference between
fiction and reality hmm III would say
that line is certainly blurred I mean
when you just look at the topic of VR
they like you go into any any Best Buy
and like I walked in there with my
daughter and I wanted to try on the VR
goggles and and there was this dinosaur
that walked over me and when I
went to go hand the goggles to my
daughter that the tech came out to meet
Sedona noise she can't put those on and
it was like why and she's like well she
has to be a certain age so of course me
I go home I start googling this like
what's the big reason why my daughter
can't wear VR glasses and they said 50%
of everyone that puts those on cannot
tell the difference between what's real
and what's not real 50% and so that led
into some research where like Cambridge
and there's some there's some pretty
high up colleges that are doing research
with it to try to help people over
phobias and they said the same thing
50% of people that have like a phobia of
flying or a phobia of getting in a crowd
can put these VR goggles and in a half
hour they can resolve that fear so what
I mean I don't you know this is just
getting into like the technology is
getting crazier and crazier but yeah
this stuff has to have an effect on you
a lot of what I want to say is in this
upcoming episode on media and violence
but I'll just say this like it it
doesn't like if if all this had no
effect on you there would be no need for
ratings right that's true that's true
right that's a good point why do we have
ratings right and there would be no need
to banned this movie in other countries
right China has banned this movie or no
it's not playing in theaters of course
they probably you would not have armed
guards at the theater like waiting for
something tragic to happen I mean that
just wouldn't even be a thought if
people were like no you're not affected
by this and the reason for it is the
government is trying to not add you know
flames to already big fire we know the
protests happening in Hong Kong and
things like that
and duker isn't the only movie that's
not being played Deadpool was never
released
Deadpool - they censored it and it was
rated our movie they brought it down to
pg-13 by deleting some scenes Wolverine
all these movies are not being played in
China Wow it was communist man more on
the ball than us so with that you're
like free speech no but you gotta wonder
why it's interesting you do you gotta
wonder why Michael we were kind of
chatting before we started this whole
show here and you had mentioned that you
had maybe a couple of things that
happened to you since you left the
Theater and you want to expound on that
a little bit so I'm gonna start with
this fact because that anything about
the lines being blurred or anything
going into the movie like yeah people go
in being like oh this is fake this is
fake this is fake but it reminds going
in minded me of my PTSD that I brought
up in the podcast with Mikey and Scotty
it it switched it stop being fake for me
and brought it back into remembering all
the dark stuff that I've had to deal
with and so I had to leave and going
outside it was this it was weird I had
literally had to be in the light and
escape the darkness interest it wasn't
this you know fun experience or or
anything when we left in the theater
because I went to see it the first time
with my cousins when we left the theater
my hands were clammy I was shaking it
was this dark this is like I needed the
Bible and I don't go anywhere without it
hmm and it was literally leaving I had
to turn on a light in the car it was
night I could not be in the darkness
because this movie I couldn't me
somebody who goes in and pulls a light
out of comics out of the comic book
movies I could not see past the PTSD it
was reminding me of had to go back into
the Bible and read that happier part I
wasn't gonna read revelation I wasn't
gonna read in Ezekiel or he's talking
about you know the sword will come down
and no I could not because the movie was
so dark
The Joker felt like the demons that I've
seen before wow that's so powerful so
even after the TV turns off when you
close the book the effects are last
and you're not the only one who's gone
and experienced this I'm someone who
wrote this is someone who watched it in
Hong Kong I watched it in Joe in Hong
Kong tonight and came out to find the
subway shut down because of the protest
it feels like the movie has not ended
Wow and you think of all the people that
have gone and watched this movie that
don't share what Michael shared I need
to just run back to Jesus I need to like
open up my Bible and how many people I
like are coming out of that with just
these dark feeling they're just
disturbing yeah and it's just
compounding like what do you walk away
with with this movie wow that's heavy
I didn't like think about that for a
second you know because it's like you
know there's so many people Michael that
say they're not affected by watching
these movies and I tell you I seen
evidence time and time again everything
affects us no I mean we're hoping that
people watch this little YouTube and get
affected by it you know I mean it's like
that's that's that's just the nature of
this it seems like we're we're all
dealing with psychological issues and
you know when it's presented with this
kind of like false hope there's no hope
it's this darkness you know that's got
to do something to society and it
doesn't always have to manifest itself
in a big way the effect doesn't have to
be so evident when we're watching things
exactly I saw a statistic that one in
four people suffer from mental health
issues but it's a spectrum you know
there's people who can't leave the house
and this people can kind of go through
the day but they're still feeling down
so it you aren't always aware of the
effects that these films are having on
you right yeah yeah it's just not a fun
it's not a fun time like I hope people
just watch this video and and decide not
to go see the Joker
because even now talking about it
thinking about it having to explain what
it was like leaving y'all looking at
each other I doubt you saw I literally
was like I had to fight back the tears
it's not a it's not a temporary thing
it's it's not a temporary thing I mean
the government put out a warning
when the movie was released - nah I'll
go opening a because they thought it was
going to happen again like it happen
with Dark Knight they thought that
somebody might come in and do it because
it's one of those type of movies it's
one of the darkest things and if
anything like the Joker might as well be
the Antichrist in the cell he might as
well be he's a political figure now he's
you know embrace it chaos
he's the Clown Prince of Crime now and
he's dressed like a mobster instead of a
clown because he's in charge that's
interesting that's interesting you know
when when I saw this scene in The Dark
Knight when Batman threw the Joker off
the roof and it caught him on his left
leg and hung him upside down in the way
that they panned that camera around very
slowly and he kind of had his arms
stretched out to me I see Christ's
parallels in the Joker for those of you
that are watching and you need a further
explanation on that we created a whole
documentary called the replacement gods
you should watch that and that'll give
you kind of a context of that but I I
see some like just twisted picture of
Christ I mean here he's hanging out with
his mother no one knows where he comes
from he's this downtrod and you know
he's got nothing he's the son of
somebody else you know and it's like
someone rich I don't know I just see all
these parallels in there that it's
better that it's like this kind of
upside down twisting world and it
becomes very evil in the comics remember
how I said that there's three people who
are the Joker's that's right which is
interesting
yeah stood out to me yes and I'm going
to explain it real quick because what
you just said I was going to use the you
know your ideas your way of looking at
comics to explain it here that the Joker
definitely felt like he was attempting
to be a christ-like figure and even I
could not pull that into the light the
thing was
is when there's three Joker's there is
the mobster Joker
there is the anarchist Joker and there's
the clown comedy Joker here's how I
would see it if we're looking at a
Christ parallel the mobster is the
father God the anarchist is Jesus and
the comedian is the Holy Spirit because
mobsters in charge and her kiss is
pretty much what the Jewish culture
thought that you know the Messiah would
be like somebody to overturn everything
politically and the comedian is the one
telling you to embrace the chaos or
embraced God and that was like when I
was remembering that in the movie it was
like this one looks like all three this
is really incredible the newest Twilight
movie has already made more than a
hundred and seventy million dollars at
the box office but there's a problem
yeah we already knew these movies made
tween girls lightheaded but there now is
a much more serious side effect
apparently here's ABC's happy Boudreaux
it's a series that has millions of fans
screaming with joy but could Twilight's
latest hit be hazardous to your health
here's a penny now moviegoers around the
country reporting certain scenes
triggering seizures like one Utah man
who passed out and began convulsing I
was shaking and same thing happened to
Brandon Gephardt in California next
thing I know I'm just I waking up to
like everyone's shaking me and the whole
theater is like looking at me last thing
you remember
fellas graphic birthing scene where
flashes of red black and white lights
flicker on the screen almost like a
strobe light people singing snorting and
trying to breathe
experts say Brandon likely suffered a
photosensitive epileptic seizure red is
one of the most provocative colors when
flashed to provoke a seizure
but it's not the first time people have
gotten sick from their favorite flicks
in 127 hours the movie about a trapped
hiker reports that moviegoers fainted
from shock during the amputation scene
even worse blockbuster avatar one man
reportedly died while watching this
movie his doctor's blaming
over-excitement
and in 2008 Cloverfield
a thriller about a monster attack in New
York City there's even a Facebook page
called Cloverfield made me sick this guy
writes loved the movie hated what it did
to my stomach
so the next time Brandon's girlfriend
wants to go to a movie maybe he should
choose something a little lighter going
back to asking the question that the
brain knows the difference between
fiction and reality they were saying
that someone had a reaction to someone
to seeing someone get their leg cut off
that's the body's natural response to go
into something that much pain but
someone just watching someone in that
much pain went into shock here's the
thing no have you ever cried in the
movie a monkey he's crying
I know I've cried why why do you cry but
why movie is affecting your emotion
right because you're fine you're
sympathizing you're going through the
experience with that person that you're
watching I think there's no denying that
that's why people like going to see in
the movies when you see these hero
movies and everybody comes out guns
blazing blow everybody away you're like
something inside of us wants to be that
hero that comes in saves the day and
wins the you know the girl or whatever
that's just built into all of us so for
those that that that really have to a
hard time understanding this point you
are affected by everything that you
watch and and you're gonna identify with
it in some way shape or form so make
sure that what you are identifying with
lines up with your Bible you know I mean
does it does it speak the same language
does it give the same outcome when you
walk away does it make you inspired for
you know treating your fellow human
beings with more sympathy and and and
loving them I'm in a movie like this
Joker I probably wouldn't be as hard on
it if it was some sort of resolution to
it
yeah if there was some sort of like hey
man there's people that are really
suffering from this this this mental
health issue here's how we need to treat
them here's how we need to do that that
that's that's christ-like you know what
I mean so I think just leaving you blank
is the problem for those people who may
have had Michaels experience you know
they left the movie kind of traumatized
I'm not really knowing what to do and
maybe they're searching online you know
how to get over how I feel about this
movie do you have any any encouragement
to those people or what does a Bible
have to say where's the hope that we can
look to when we're surrounded by a world
filled with darkness you know I I think
the Bible is full of promises and there
is a lot of amazing promises that that
you can stand on and and take that as as
you know this is God speaking to us he
he doesn't have plans to harm us to hurt
us he has plans that we thrive plans
that we do better
Jeremiah 29:11 nice and right on you
know what I mean and I think that that
if we kind of began to look at well what
is Christianity really offering it
should be this this this peace that
passes all understanding I mean these
are things that the Bible describes that
that God is wanting to give to us so the
more that we can can you know run to
that stand on those promises and say God
you promised to do this for me I believe
it will make a life-changing
transformation in your life it's
important for Christians to not just
close their eyes to these matters but to
reach out to people and offer help what
did you run to Michael with burst I was
trying to find it it was the one that I
showed on the podcast us it was 1st or
2nd Timothy you know I've given you a
spirit not a fear with that of some I'm
sorry gentlemen that was the bad worse
that I immediately went to because if I
didn't do that my head would have been
screwed up for way too long
John 3:16 for God so loved the world
like he did that for me I don't
worried about the darkness anyone Jesus
Jesus came to give us life and give it
abundantly not take it away I mean the
thief comes to steal and kill I found a
Bible first of that John 14:27 peace I
leave with you my peace I give unto you
not as the world gives do I give to you
do not let your heart be troubled nor
let it be fearful that's good this is in
Psalm 147 3 that he heals the
brokenhearted and binds up their wounds
so if we've been damaged in some way God
is there to make everything right
vengeance is the easy road it's easy
road that leads to more pain you know
studies have shown that the best way to
overcome depression certain levels of
depression of course and other mental
health issues is to give selflessly the
get involved in selfless service and the
church is heavily involved in that I'm
so to try to bring more people into that
instead of staying in our communities
trying to bring others into that kind of
service it will be a big help to society
that's right and and you know I've
watched a lot of videos of Holocaust
survivors that I mean you can imagine
what like some of these people have been
tested in and you know done evil evil
things too and every year the Holocaust
survivors still to this day get together
over there and arch witson and you know
they remember what happened to them and
there's even a group that that goes gets
together and and actually forgave all of
the Germans and they talk about their
experience of moving beyond the evil
that was done to them and they've lived
wonderful lives and so you know
forgiveness is a big part of it I mean
who hasn't been wronged right some more
than others but adding that forgiveness
element can also help us to move past
those broken feelings and begin to heal
there is a guy who's who a cop went into
the wrong house or something and shot
the owner did you hear about that yeah
and and the brother of the guy who just
got killed said
the judge can I hug her you know and he
was a Christian too you know and that
impacted a lot of people yeah viral all
right well thank you so much Michael for
joining us in this conversation and for
the viewers thank you so much for tuning
in if you've seen the joke or any kind
of movie as such and you walked away but
were able to find a piece or or some
kind of encouragement through the Word
of God please leave a comment down below
with that Bible text with that
encouragement and maybe some suggestions
of better movies that bring awareness to
mental health and a more positive and
more encouraging way we would really
appreciate that we want to build a
community this is not just us bashing
these films or really trying to bring
our own sort of awareness and to spread
Christ because he is the answer to to
these societal issues please remember to
like and subscribe share this video to
as many people as possible down below
you can find all the links to our
patreon to our website to get some cool
t-shirts and we just want to thank you
guys so much for tuning in every single
Friday we will see you next week on LED
live bye bye alright
[Music]